[Music]
of course everybody loves watching viral
video right especially the kids they
love their viral videos but we feel bad
for all those YouTube videos and there
are a lot of them that just get a few
dozen views you know people put them up
people only seem to focus on the ones
that get millions and millions of views
no one pays attention to the viral
videos that people put up there and they
have a lot of hopes and a lot of dreams
and then 11 people check it out well I
decided to try and take an unpopular
YouTube video and turn it into a hit
with our new segment celebrity YouTube
view boost all right here's how it works
we find a YouTube video that has under
100 views then we add a celebrity and
repost the video on our own YouTube page
boom instant viral hit or at least
another 100 years
yeah about that yeah anyway tonight's
video is called best dancing baby
alright this is a real video we found
100 views nothing's happening with it
let's take a look ready stand up and
boogie oh go go AJ go Gigi
all right well cute kid but that video
is going nowhere fast yeah yeah now
though leave it to us let's add guitar
God's slash into the mix turn that video
into a viral hit roll it ready stand up
and boogie
[Music]
goal AJ
[Applause]
that thing's going through the roof yeah
that things going all the way
hmm oh yeah well anyway we'll check in
with that and uh what a couple of months
how does it work I don't know